when you think that you are saving the
world you become a fundamentalist
because that's the most important thing
and it's worth sacrificing everything
else people who adopt that okay we're
saving the world you because you're not
with us you are a threat to the world to
the planet itself so people who believe
that they emanate the stink of
self-righteousness that just turns other
people off
charles eisenstein welcome to the show
happy to be here chris
right so i wanted to get you on because
recently i had a discussion around
climate with patrick moore who is the
ex-president of greenpeace
and as a part of that it
it really got me thinking about the
state of the climate debate at the
moment seeing the way that the comments
kicked off seeing how it makes people
sort of very viscerally involved
and
what it kind of taught me was the
climate debate is
mostly
[ __ ] like it's mostly just a mess
and
i think that it's obvious a lot of
people have tied their colors to
particular flagpoles that this is
something which is very
very tribal in a way that i don't think
climate should be and obviously i've
seen this right i've watched people get
crazy about climate and glue their
breasts to the street and lock down
motorways in the uk and throw pigs blood
on people coming out of canada goose
stores but i'd never
been
as close to the conversation as i have
been with this and i
wanted to get someone on i mean even
this month i tweeted out saying
i want to get an impartial climate
scientist on
any suggestions
most of the suggestions from people were
impartial climate scientists don't exist
no one that does that i someone said
that by using the word impartial you're
already adding you you're already trying
to put some sort of a spin on it we
should just be bothered about the data
i'm not hang on a second like that's
what impartial means like i'm
so
yeah like if if you call it impartial
then you're gonna get criticized for
uh
uh suggesting that there are even two
viable sides to correct yes yeah yeah
yeah exactly there's some sort of
narrative and counter narrative which
anyone that can't see that there is so i
was just like look i need to get
somebody on
that i can just thrash this out with and
can kind of help me
understand the state of the climate
debate at the moment so um
yeah give me a hand
yep well
what i'm going to say is true in pretty
much any polarized debate
which is that the key to unlocking it
lies in the questions neither side is
asking
and the secret assumptions that both
sides share
so they get stuck in a debate that is
defined by the terms of the debate and
and not what they're not looking at
so in the term in in the case of climate
you have one side that says
because of
carbon emissions and greenhouse gas
emissions we're at the
at or past multiple tipping points that
are going to cause runaway global
warming and
the end of civilization as we know it or
worse
that's what one side
essentially says and there's some that
are more alarmist than others
and the other side
basically says
no carbon dioxide really isn't a problem
they're
warming if there is any it's not runaway
and
there's nothing to worry about as far as
the environment goes because
global warming is not an issue okay
what
both sides agree on is that the
conversation the primary environmental
conversation
is about carbon dioxide and greenhouse
gases
so i wrote a book about this topic uh
called climate a new story
and what i came to in the research
and in the the meditation and in the
uh whatever legal and illegal
investigations i did into the nature of
life
what i came to is that
the planet earth is alive
its organs
are things like
soil water
forests wetlands
species fish whales
every ecosystem every species is an
organ of a living being
therefore
if we
continue to cut down the forests
overfish the oceans
develop the wetlands drain the swamps
destroy the soil etc etc poison the
water
then it doesn't matter if we cut
emissions to zero because earth will
still die a death of a million cuts
because it would be like
if you had
like suppose you had a runaway
temperature
and it was because
your organs are all getting eaten alive
by uh
some you know by a flesh-eating bacteria
and you're like oh man temperatures
rising better take some you know
medicine to reduce my temperature it's
like no your your organs are being
destroyed
so what i came to is that
where our attention as environmentalists
needs to go
is to
the the
sacred
living
nature
of this planet and to devote our care
into protecting and healing all that's
been damaged
which is a completely different emphasis
than
the standard narrative of climate change
and i could say way more about it but i
don't want to like you know talk for a
whole hour so
maybe it's a starting point
yeah i think
when we're talking about the specifics
like that so patrick
specifically seems to have really
positioned himself to
be account and a counter voice to each
individual thing so whether it be sea
rising or reductions of the size of the
ice caps or deforestation in the amazon
or the number of
animals that are going extinct his
argument essentially was that look we
have far more degrees of freedom with
this than we think that deforestation
and reforestation are occurring at
similar times that increases in co2 are
allowing reforestation to occur in arid
areas because there's more co2 for
plants to live in and so on and so forth
which i'm sure the arguments that you're
familiar with
and there's this one comment man out of
i think it's 150 000 hours that that
episode's been watched in a couple of
weeks
and a lot of comments but one of the
ones that popped up one of the one of
the teams sent to me and they said
when i hear someone someone that
explains the climate change it sounds
comprehensible when i hear someone that
explains that climate change is not real
it also sounds comprehensible i really
don't know what to think about this
topic anymore and to be honest like
that's where i am that's my position
yeah i came to that too when i like very
few
climate activists spend any time deeply
investigating the work of the climate
skeptics
and when when i did that i'm like you
know like
some issues i'm like okay
i could
refute this but on other issues i'm like
you know they really have a point here
and what i came to
is that it is really dangerous for
environmentalists to hitch their wagon
to the global warming horse
because what if that horse gets tired as
this guy patrick moore is
saying you know like maybe the ice caps
aren't actually melting i mean like i
remember like they were predicting
that
that the arctic would be ice free by
2015 you know like that didn't happen
like
what if what if the skeptics are right
and we've hitched our wagon like of
fracking pipelines
like all this all these stuff we've said
we can't do that anymore because climate
change well what if
you know that runs out of steam
what i came to is like i don't actually
care
if
it's causing
climate change i still want
oil
exploration in the inner niger delta
which is displacing millions of people
and destroying pristine wetlands
and
making oil spills that are like
endangering children and like i still
want that to stop
i still have like have you seen the tar
sands excavation photos
in canada you know like these beautiful
forests turn into this
this hellscape of like pits you know and
and
dead trees you know and pollution like
i want that to stop i want the earth to
be beautiful
it doesn't and and i think that
environmentalism used to be about that
in the 60s it wasn't save the whales
because if we don't bad things are going
to happen to us
it was save the whales because they are
magnificent beings
environmentalism fundamentally has to be
motivated by love
and love is not
love of life
love of this earth love of not just the
amazon but of like the forest behind
your house
of the place where you grew up
of the animals that you interact with
not because they have some instrumental
utility
and and that we should navigate
according to some complicated
self-interest calculation
that's not why we're here as human
beings we're not here
to maximize our rational self-interest
what do you think it's being motivated
by at the moment from the
environmentalist side
i think it is actually motivated by love
but
the rhetoric
is about fear
the rhetoric is about
force it's about for example let's
pressure and force
people to change
let's force the corporations to change
but like
and i'm not saying that that
you know we should just always ask
nicely for change but we have to
understand that
pretty much every human being on some
level cares about this world
and cares about the beings on it not
because of some threat
to themselves to their prophets and so
forth
environmentalism has to return to that
otherwise we're going to be in a war
i think that's what
turned
me off
from a lot of the environmentalist
movement was this
inherent
sort of
sense that i was a bad guy
if i drove my car or i was a bad guy if
i wasn't going vegan or i was a bad guy
if i didn't use recyclable plastics or
something uh alex epstein calls it human
racism
and um that's a really really good term
for it this sort of self-hatred of
humanity on the whole that the planet
would be beautiful and perfect without
us here and that we're this sort of
scourge on the earth
and it's wrong
i i'm going to try and risk all the
listen all the ways i think it's wrong
it's wrong because psychologically that
is not the way to get people to buy into
your argument if you truly want to
actually get change if you want people
to agree with your position
you cannot no one's ever been shamed
into like willful compliance and support
of a cause they might be grudgingly
supportive cause but they're not going
to do it because they want to they're
just going to think [ __ ] hell lisa
down the street in a furry coat isn't
going to shut up if i don't make sure
that my blue bins are out at night to
recycle all of my cans uh i think it's a
bad idea because
it polarizes the conversation it means
that you can't ever have a
uh how would you say
there's no way to discuss this in a a
well-meaning good faith delicate manner
it's always got to be louder and bigger
and more militant
um
and i think that that's what's causing
this oh that's at least part of what's
causing this divide you have people
going well hang on a second you're
telling me
you're telling me that i'm some sort of
a bad guy [ __ ] you i'm not a bad guy
yeah and it just rolls down the hill
from there man the slinky starts moving
yeah yeah the the
like part of the
save the world narrative
which
like that's already a red flag for me
there's an awful lot have been harm a
lot of harm that's been done
historically by people who are trying to
save the world
like do you know what the last big save
the world campaign was
that was
fully grounded in
almost universally accepted science
it was eugenics
big threat to humanity was genetic
degradation and the solution was
to
sterilize
the unfit
and you know
most scientists most doctors and most
educated people believed in that
and we saw what
you know the result
play out um
in the
first half of the 20th century
and that's not i'm not trying to equate
you know climate change activism with
fascism or anything like that
but it's just like
when you think that you are saving the
world
you become a fundamentalist because
that's the most important thing and it's
worth sacrificing everything else to
that god
another problem with it in addition to
what you mentioned is that people who
adopt that okay we're saving the world
you
because you're not with us you are a
threat to the to the world to the planet
itself
so so people who
believe that they emanate the stink of
self-righteousness that just turns other
people off
and as far as
because like on some level you know that
you are not a bad guy
i mean assuming that you're not you know
like a full-blown psychopath or whatever
like
you have your heart knows the truth
that you care
about life
and when somebody is telling you
that
you are bad or believes that you're bad
you're going to reject them
as not a carrier of truth
same thing for humanity as a whole
like yeah i'm well familiar with this
narrative that human beings are a plague
on the planet
and i think
so
are are you saying that we are nature's
big mistake
that the gifts that make us human
are worthless
that would make us an exception to every
other species on earth every species on
earth has unique
characteristics
that enhance
the resiliency and the robustness of the
ecosystem and that propel evolution
to a new step
are humans an exception to that
are
are we just the the evil beings that are
in the way of beauty and life
or is it that we have not yet
applied
the gifts that make us human toward
their true purpose
as a civilization
and what is that
it's to
contribute
to the furtherance of life and beauty on
earth
to make the world even more alive and
more beautiful
what do you think the climate skeptics
movement is getting wrong
the big thing is that there is no
problem there is no environmental
problem a lot of them not all of them
but a lot of them
throw out the baby with the bathwater
not only do they
level what i think is
a at least an arguable
it's not like a crazy critique of global
warming but then they tend to lump in
every other environmental problem and
say environmentalism is just a way to
facilitate a socialist takeover and so
on and so forth
like
i mean i my with my own two eyes i've
seen
i mean just like you know like there's a
debate is there an insect apocalypse or
not you know like there's all these
studies about the rapid decline of
insect numbers
insect
um
80 in a lot of places
and i'm like yeah you know when i was a
kid
and we went for trips
the windshield would get covered with
bug splatter
and now like on a long trip there's like
two or three bugs maybe
something has changed
my my brother lives on a farm
uh
there the the uh there's some streams
that you know come down from the
mountain
and in the summer they often go dry and
there's like you know kind of a muddy
puddle here and there
he was walking the farm with an old
timer who grew up there
and he said yeah back in the 40s
these streams were so full that you
could not cross
without waiting boots
all summer
so
something is
like and even the stuff about about
reforestation and stuff
like
for like the number of the the land area
of virgin forests
is shrinking and the land area under
tree plantations is growing biofuels
plantations is growing you can call
those a forest but they're a lot less
alive than if you've ever been in in a
old growth forest and i mean you can
feel the force looking at you like
there's a spirit there this is the kind
of perception we have to tap into if
we're going to live on a different way
on earth and in relation to earth
so so yeah the skeptics what they're
not seeing
is simply the sacredness
and the the
importance
of life
one of the things that's interesting
there that venn diagram that crossover
between
being skeptical about this and then it
being a globalist socialist takeover or
whatever it might be i was driving
through newcastle's city center
and
there was a
anti-vaccine
protest
i'm not sure if it was for children but
i don't think it's being mandated for
children in the uk anyway so anyway
anti-vaccine protesters i'm going past
and um it was on september 11th
on the same day so i'm driving past and
it was traffic everywhere because the
police are everywhere so i'm sat and
these people have got megaphones and
they're shouting out and they've got
their banners saying no vaccines and
blah blah blah and i'm like oh cool like
it's interesting you don't really see it
quite so much in the uk i know that
america you guys love it love a protest
uh but in the uk we've got a bit fewer
of them
and then
the lady came on the
on the megaphone
and said right we are now going to have
a one minutes silence
for the victims of the september 11th
inside job as i
oh
this is a vaccine
thing that and you've also like the
streams have been crossed here and
you've decided
for some reason that because the vaccine
like there's a big bunch of people here
that here for anti-vaccines but also
believe that september 11th is an inside
job these two things aren't linked
like whether september 11th is an inside
job or whether the vaccine mandate is
you trying to have a globalist
totalitarian takeover
but there was a lot of people that did
that and i think that you see
uh particular personalities get drawn
towards certain movements because it's
seductive in one form or another and yes
i think that
it leads to people having
distilled blind spots right you become
incredibly conscious of certain things
and incredibly blind to others
yeah so i think one thing going on there
is um i speak of it in terms of the
disintegration of
the uh
the story
or even the mythology
that
helps us make sense of the world
uh
that that tells us what things mean that
tells us what's real tells us who we are
how to live these stories are breaking
down because they're not working anymore
so
so for example somebody who once
pretty much believed the dominant
narratives
about
you know
like
how to be healthy for example you go to
the doctor and the doctor fixes you and
science is progressing and people are
getting healthier and healthier and they
can fix more and more things you know
and then
you get some autoimmune condition for
example
that was extremely rare 50 years ago
and
the doctor can't fix it and like you and
then maybe you go to an alternative
healer eventually when you get desperate
and they can fix it
you're like okay
what i've been told
is not true
what else am i being told
that you know might also not be true
so there's this creeping radicalism and
it's quite
normal almost to flip from
everything they're telling us is true to
nothing they are telling us is true
everything is
a conspiracy everything is a hoax
everything's a lie and people go down
the rabbit hole i mean 911
um
uh truther i mean that's
not actually that
far
you know that's i mean you know there
are people out there who are
believe the moon landings were faked um
who believe that earth is flat
who believe nuclear weapons are hoaxes
and
you know that that the sandy hook school
shooting was fake and like all these
things
um
and and you know like
people
it's so comforting to have a story of
everything
a totalizing narrative that tells you
that that gives you the illusion of
control in the world
that gives you an illusion of certainty
that tells you here's your place here's
how to live like that's comforting so
when that is
stripped away when that crumbles people
often jump to another totalizing
narrative which could be a cult you know
it could be like they join a cult
or a radical political movement or or q
anon or something like that
and and really where we have to go is
into the place of
being comfortable with not knowing
maybe some things were being told by the
authorities are true
and some aren't
maybe
the vaccines are
much more dangerous and less effective
than we're told yet they're not a
diabolical plot by reptilian aliens to
call the sheep
you know like
that place of uncertainty
is uncomfortable
for a lot of people and it applies to
the climate debate too like what if the
biosphere is
um becoming increasingly deranged and
unstable and there isn't one thing
that we can use to explain it all
that's called fundamentalism i call it
carbon fundamentalism the one thing and
if we could only it's so so
uh
comfortable to have one thing that's the
enemy and the key to all your problems
it's that's why in a way like
the virus like the coronavirus
was a relief because
here we have
declining health all of these ambient
anxieties and fears and here's something
you can be afraid of here's something
you can control it's an identifiable
pathogen
so we can
you know
walk down quarantine distance et cetera
et cetera and now i'm safe
so with the degradation of the biosphere
it's the same thing it's it's it's
painful to to watch
watch it happen oh and here's one thing
an enemy
let's find an enemy and attack the enemy
that is
a pattern of action
that civilization as we know it is quite
familiar with like yeah
has there ever been a time in history
where humans have
been able to deal
with uncertainty
effectively in that way and reach
aristotle's virtuous mean
well i think that the way that humans
learn to deal with uncertainty
is uh by going through it
you know it's an initiation
and it's it's it's a
growth process you inhabit
one certainty one story one self
um
and it works for a while
eventually it becomes
um
no longer hospitable
like you grow out of it you become
something that no longer fits into that
story
what i'm thinking what i'm thinking is
that for a long time it was religion
for an awful long time the single
narrative that we had that explained
everything that we were able to put our
faith in was that faith itself god's
higher purpose whatever the ideology was
that would carry us through
and [ __ ] man like if i don't hear if i
if i try and have a conversation about
some of the challenges that we're facing
in the modern era that doesn't come back
to
should we have just not got rid of
religion um
i it's it continues to come up whether
it's identity politics whether it's
politics and extremism whether it's the
climate debate
i think that people struggle to be in
uncertainty i think it's inherently
uncomfortable for humans and i think
that previously we could outsource this
sense of uncertainty because if we feel
uncertainty there is something solid
that we can wrap ourselves around and
that's religion
and now
what is that to hold on to you've got to
make your own meaning you've got to find
your own purpose religion's out the
window man
well what happened was religion was
replaced by a new religion called
science
science is a religion
and i'm not saying that it's just a
religion
or that religion is bad
but it's a religion it rests on
metaphysical principles that are taken
for granted such as
everything
that is real can be quantified and
measured such as
variables can be controlled
such as experiments are in theory
repeatable
that they don't depend on the attitude
of the experimenter and the place and
time where he is
um
that there's an objective world outside
of ourselves like these these are a few
of the metaphysical assumptions of
science
and then you have a priesthood
that speaks in their own special
language
you have
true believers you have heretics who get
excommunicated when they lose their
funding you have a long training ordeal
called graduate school to initiate you
into the priesthood
you have a system for indoctrinating the
youth
i mean the whole thing
it tells you how the world began like a
religion does
tells you the nature of a human being
the whole thing is religion
and it has provided that certainty that
you were talking about for a long time
but now it is breaking down
it's breaking down because the paradise
that it promised
has not come to pass like we were this
is 2021 man that like you're maybe a
little younger than me but when i was a
kid
even the year 2000 was like this
impossibly futuristic paradise
you know 2021 i mean we were supposed to
be like
you know gods by now
but instead life has gotten worse
people are for example less healthy
than they were 50 years ago
life expectancy is plateauing and
starting to decline in the uk and the
united states is that really true
yeah
yeah life expectancy rose in the first
half of the 20th century it rose by 26
years
in the u.s
in the second half of the 20th century
it rose by maybe six years
and
now it's it's plateaued and even before
covet it was starting to decline so
and we didn't
like another promise was we were going
to engineer
all poverty and crime out of existence
political science was going to give us a
perfect government i mean
it didn't happen so we're losing faith
in science and people are having
experiences that don't fit into science
that science says are impossible so this
is even more uncertainty
yeah
so so basically we are facing a
religious crisis right now just like the
one
that
that that the west faced you know 300
years ago
um in the transition from
christianity to science we're facing
another one right now that's profoundly
disorienting i suppose an interesting
thing is that with science you can have
in the same way as you can have multiple
interpretations of scripture or use
different translations the same data
can be interpreted by two different
people to reach completely opposite
conclusions so when we're talking about
the co2 parts per million and patrick
was talking about it's the milankovitch
cycle on this 80 000 year tilt of the
way that jupiter affects the axis of the
earth's tilt and wobble and blah blah
and you know
that sounds plausible
that sounds like it might be true and
then if you sit and listen to a greta
thundberg or an extinction rebellion
person for a little one of the
karma less unhinged ones and you're like
well
that sounds
that sounds plausible like i know that
we make more carbon dioxide i know that
my car puts out fumes out the back of it
i don't really know too much but you
think you go okay so you've got sort of
two
it's the same world everyone's
inhabiting the same world and somehow
coming to completely opposite
conclusions about it whilst relying on
the thing that's supposed to be
independent the science
yeah yeah like these scientists in a way
that like another way that they're like
priests is that they perform these
divination rituals
using their sanctified instruments
their their microscopes their computers
and like it's like consulting an oracle
and then they come and tell the public
what the future is going to be
and now like you're saying there's
basically a schism
and some of the priests are telling us
one thing and a minority of them are
telling us something else and yeah how
do you know what to believe
you can go and look at the data yourself
and make your own interpretations but
if even phds are vehemently disagreeing
on the interpretation of it
and even more today even on the validity
of the data itself
because it's like well that data has
been adjusted you know
and and and the more that
science is politicized and woven into
political narratives
that
are weaponized to defeat the other side
the less reliable data is because if
your goal is to defeat the other side
then
it's totally
justified to
change the data or or to be
very
hostile
to data that doesn't fit your narrative
and subject it to intense scrutiny but
if it does fit your narrative you just
welcome that i mean we see this
happening in all the covid the vaccine
conversations as well
so so how do you know how can you choose
it's it's
in a way like if you're honest with
yourself today there's no choice but to
be uncertain yeah that's what that
message that's what that comment said
man when i hear someone that explains
the climate change it sounds
comprehensible when i hear someone that
explains that climate change is not real
it also sounds comprehensible i really
don't know what to think on this topic
anymore you're like dude i had to get
this story up for you john stossel do
you know who john stossel is due to the
moustache like a american reporter
journalisty dude john stossel sues
facebook alleging defamation of a fact
check label seeks at least two million
dollars former tv journalist john
stossel is demanding at least two
million dollars in damages from facebook
in a lawsuit who filed against the
social media giant alleging the company
defamed him by appending fact-checking
labels to two videos he posted about
climate change in a statement a variety
facebook spokesperson says we believe
this case is without merit and we will
defend ourselves vigorously against the
allegations blah blah blah in one video
government fueled fires about 2020
wildfires in california fact-checking
partners falsely attributed to stossel a
claim he never made on the basis that
flag the flag content was misleading and
missing context so that viewers would be
rooted to the false attribution
statement blah blah blah back and forth
and you think right okay not only now
is it useful politically to further a
particular cause one side of the aisle
or another or an agenda or to get people
to feel one way to create this sort of
ambient sense of outrage or anxiety or
whatever
but individuals
now
are profiting from this you have
individual people i'm going to be the
climate scientist that's going to be you
know patrick moore for all that he may
or may not have good intentions he's
trying to sell some books like he's
trying to sell books and for as long as
you're trying to sell books you do not
have
the purest intentions at heart because
there are perverse incentives there the
incentives are for you to come up with
something which is maybe a bit more
bombastic maybe a little bit more
exciting than it would have been
and that john stossel thing as well like
it's on the side of facebook to achieve
appear impartial it's on the side of
john stossel to try and
battle back and use it to get more clout
and then to get money out of them
yeah i tend not to
attribute
it attribute people's um
militant opinions too much to wanting to
make money
i think like there's
psychological
forces that are at work that are more
powerful like wanting to belong
wanting to seek approval from
you know a certain segment of the
population at least taking sides taking
sides is psychologically satisfying
because now
you belong
now you are accepted now you
have
external allies
that tell you that you are good because
you're on team good in the war on evil
and at a time when
um the stories that help us create an
identity through participation in a
common goal or breaking down
people are having an identity crisis and
therefore they gravitate toward partisan
political
and other opinions does that make sense
like yeah yeah yeah like yeah because we
used to have a unifying story
of civilization
it didn't include everybody but it was a
pretty broad unifying story that you
knew
yeah
yeah it was of ascent it was of progress
and you know you're an ambitious young
man well
here's what to do you become a rocket
scientist you become a doctor you become
even a lawyer because you become a
functioning productive member of society
and you are part of this glorious ascent
of humanity toward this you know amazing
future like that infused life with
meaning and we don't have that anymore
and people are just
grasping struggling to make life mean
something
how much do you think i keep hearing
problems of the modern era attributed to
the fact that this is the first
generation who hasn't done better than
their parents
and i definitely
think that there's a sense of that going
on if you hear
the sort of language that greta
thumbberg
uses
where she talks about you are destroying
our future
you
older people people who had it
great who've
raped mother earth for all that she is
worth and so on and so forth and then we
are paying the price and you're not
going to be here but we are and it's our
job to fix it
it feels like that's an element as well
that as we're talking about perhaps some
of the promises of technology and
science starting to top out or at least
slow down
that's causing
the deceleration is being felt by people
and they're going whoa whoa hang on a
second something's wrong maybe we need
to try and kickstart this star again
yeah
you know the irony
the irony is that that
well for one thing that you know all of
this ecological destruction
hasn't actually worked you know i mean
if if we're making us happier and
happier
maybe you could
justify it
but it's not even doing that
and
the irony is that
our
happiness
fulfillment
joy
thriving
is actually readily available and it
doesn't depend on more technology more
resource consumption or anything like
that
i don't know if you've traveled a lot
but
if you have like where do you find the
happiest people
are they in london
are they in tokyo are they in new york
or are they in
you know
uh
the gambia dude happiest happiest people
that i ever met were in a town called
pai which is the most northern town in
thailand
and i volunteered at a uh elephant
sanctuary and reforestation
site for a while and this town's got a
lot it's main street is a large dirt
road and all of the others are small
dirt roads and i rock up and i'm on a
moped for the first time and got small
swim shots on and i'm going around
washing these elephants and helping
people dig holes in the ground and it
was just pure bliss
and it sounds so
new age and hippie and kind of
unsustainable it sounds like it's the
sort of thing that by its very nature is
a holiday you go well
i don't know man like what are we doing
things in what's life in service of
if it's not
pure fulfillment and joy in the moment
how much are we over complicating the
situ the ends now have repurposed the
means to a point where you're like well
everything's everything's been turned
upside down those are the happiest
people i ever saw people in a a city
that you have to travel for four hours
on a road that's literally called vomit
vomit motorway because it's got so many
bends that people throw up tourists
throw up in the van on the way there
they're the happiest people i ever met
yeah
yeah and and if
and their you know gdp per capita is
probably very low
they're the
btus of energy that they consume per
capita are very low
a place like that is a
ripe target for what's called
economic development
and when those people
stop engaging in their traditional
livelihoods stop producing their own
food and cooking for each other and
building their own houses and doing all
that stuff in a gift economy
and begin purchasing things and working
for global corporations
their gdp goes up
and
in the statistics it looks like their
quality of life has improved
and their resource consumption goes up
too
so really like to take it back to you
know climate change and stuff i mean
really what this whole thing is about
is the question how to be human
and we are
as a species or at least as a
civilization
reconsidering
that question we're facing the
bankruptcy of the answer that we had
been pursuing for a long time
and therefore everything
is on the table now
everything what was a better step to
move forward when you wrote your book
did you think about
some recommendations for
a better way to have this discussion
um i mean i had like you know a bunch of
practical policy recommendations
uh new priorities but the animating
principle under those priorities is is
love of life
so i said first priority is to preserve
whatever
pristine ecosystems are still here
which is like especially the amazon the
congo
um but even like any small wetlands
um or
or
like any place that is has health in it
we protect it
and the second priority is to
restore
regenerate
the
broken places
especially agricultural soils
and then third is to
stop dousing the world and poison all
the time
multiple you know
herbicides
uh insecticides
uh toxic waste
radioactive waste electromagnetic
pollution etc etc
i think that is
partly what's behind the insect
apocalypse
and then fourth priority
and in my mind it's a distant fourth
is to reduce carbon emissions
can't hurt you know it's putting like
more stress
on a system that's already stressed
so
but as far as like how do we talk about
it yeah
the the
the principle is
whatever you say it comes from a trust
in
our collective purpose and the purpose
of each individual human being
which is
to contribute to life and beauty on
earth
and when i speak to anybody it could be
you know
uh
exxon mobil executive
and i'm i'm standing in the knowing that
this person on a deep level cares about
life
has places that are special to him and
that on some level
wants to serve life
wants to be a force for
for positive change in the world if i
stand strongly in that
then
he knows that i'm an ally
he knows that i'm actually on some level
on his side
even if i disagree with his opinions and
he'll listen to me
he won't be
like he he people can feel
how you see them
people have a have a internal
uh
guidance system
like we can sense
and if i'm
truly
willing
to see the best
in him
then
my words will have power he'll trust me
he'll know that i'm not just trying to
convert him i'm not trying to convince
him
i'm not trying to dominate him
to like
fight his evidence and logic with my
superior evidence and logic and make him
run away with his tail between his legs
this is because what i was saying is is
the nature of the revolution that we are
in right now is
in
how we understand ourselves to be
who we are
therefore who we are being
and we have to stand in
the new human which is actually the
ancient human also
the new human which is like yeah i am
here to give to the world
i'm here to to to receive and to give
to be part of evolution to be part of
the planet coming more and more alive
every stage of evolution has been
becoming more alive of the planet
from the first eukaryotic cells
to the first multicellular organisms to
plants to flowering trees like the world
got more and more and more alive that's
that's what life wants
it's to live
and we are the latest creation of nature
for the same thing
when we stand in that and see each other
as that
then
we'll we'll figure out what to do
the
fact that every conversation
appears to have the worst possible
intentions if you're on opposite sides
of the fence
it's always a presumption that you are
coming at this with an agenda or some
sort of bad faith or whatever there
doesn't seem to be any benefit of the
doubt given to people there doesn't seem
to be any hope or any redemption or any
possibility that they may not see the
world in the same way that you do so
what do you think's more like like
they're convinced by their view
obviously that's why they hold it
there's very very few people who
actually actively hold a view with which
they internally disagree
but almost no one does that
so why do you think the person that sat
across from you believes the thing that
they do because they see the world in a
different way that convictions are
alternate to yours
and yet
there seems to be such
everyone's so quick to throw bad faith
or grifter or shill or whatever
terminology you want at the at the other
side idiot
willful killer of the of the world
uh vegan
stupid people stopping people getting to
work in the morning on a motorway
and
i think that's
that
level of aggression
and animus
in the conversation
is it facilitated by frictionless
communication online yeah maybe
probably probably a bit of it uh is it
communicated by fracturing permitting
people to fracture into different and
different subgroups and having no grand
narrative that holds them together over
the top yeah yeah probably when you
throw all of this together
kind of doesn't surprise me that
this is a challenge
that we're facing and we see it with
everything politics education
child care gender
race
economics whatever you want
[ __ ] pandemics
yeah
fractured frictionless
yeah and it comes again to the crisis in
belonging you know when you when you ask
well why does somebody have the beliefs
and convictions
that they have
is it because they made a dispassionate
survey of all of the possibilities
and applied critical thinking
and sifted through all the data
no usually people believe what is
convenient for them to believe
convenient in what sense
it
fits in with other things that they
believe it
garners the approval of people around
them
it enables them to say that they are a
good person
it
um helps them to belong to a community
of other people who hold the same
beliefs
so people naturally gravitate toward
those kinds of beliefs
[Music]
that's
one of my favorite sayings is you cannot
reason somebody out of a belief that
they didn't reason themselves into to
begin with
so yeah this is
i mean human nature this is human nature
because we are social animals
and and
for thousands of years the most
important thing was
the acceptance of the group
in ancient times the worst punishment
wasn't even execution
it was ostracism
banishment
which probably amounted to execution
because people were
dependent on each other
but you know it i mean i've
you know
been subjected to a certain amount of
canceling and denunciation online
and man it hurts you know what i mean
like on a deep level
it's it's it's really distressing
and yeah like i can grow a thick skin
you know and but when when it happens my
instinct is to find my tribe
find the people who say oh yeah those
[ __ ] are just totally wrong and
they're they're you know
some human in some way unlike us i'm
like ah yeah my people and and i
recognize that pattern
as
very close to the origin of the problem
that that tribalism that mob mentality
where where
social tension is relieved by turning on
some victim
and i better make sure that i'm not that
victim i better
uh you know
be tight with my folks
so that i don't get dehumanized and
victimized
scapegoated
the world isn't right and wrong anymore
it's in groups and out groups all the
way down that's all there is
yes and and
that whole thing it sounds dark but
that's not all there is to human nature
there's also a transcendent dimension
that we
are we are being presented with right
now as a choice
and it's about
it's about compassion it's about
forgiveness it's about putting yourself
in someone else's shoes it's about
generosity of listening it's about
humility
it's about
humbling yourself to what's true
even if
it might not fit in with your self-image
even if it might mean that you were
wrong about something because let's face
it everybody
everybody listening to this is probably
wrong about something
one of their deep convictions
if you are
okay if you are how are you ever going
to know that
when
that is
so
part of your identity
like like if and if you want the other
people the wrong side
to ever change their mind
then you have to be willing to change
your mind too
otherwise if you're not willing because
you just know you're right
you're setting an example of
the human being that they're going to
conform to too
they know they're right just as much as
you know you're right
so
what is
and that's not to to say like betray
what you genuinely know but it's to look
at okay the things i believe how many of
them do i know from direct experience
why do i believe the things that i
believe
and what would it be like to not believe
them what would i lose
to not believe them
and
am i
willing
to not believe them
or are those things i would lose too
precious that even if i'm wrong
i am not going to let go of this belief
like let's get honest with ourselves
first
then we have the possibility of actual
conversation
rather than the debate or really the
shouting match that prevails
in
public discourse today
perfect place to leave it man thank you
so much charles eisenstein ladies and
gentlemen if people want to keep up to
date with what it is that you do where
should they go
um
i have a uh my website is kind of in
stasis right now so sub stack i have a
uh
a blog on sub stack that i'm publishing
right now
charleseisenstein.substack.com
i believe so yes cool i'll find it i'll
put it in the show notes below charles
thanks so much for today yeah thanks
chris thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace